but we've had things get delayed like
you don't mess with the zohan
so
adam says to me adam sandler do you want
to write this movie with robert smeigle
about a hairdresser
a mossad agent in israel who wants to
move america to america and retire
and be a hairdresser
and
so i worked on that with robert
schmeichel who's the best comedy writer
in the world
so
we had a script we really liked in
like 2000
around that time
and then
911
happens
and we were like oh
i guess you can't do that
now
like everything about what we're
satirizing is much more
heated right
i think we
put it in a trunk before 9 11
when there was the intifada
a year or two before that
and then
every once while
we would take a run at could you rewrite
it i thought after 9 11 there was a way
to do the movie about a cell a terrorist
cell and i i was saying you know can't
we do it about
rob schneider is in a terrorist cell
and he slowly falls in love with america
and then in the end he doesn't want to
do it and that he teams up with adam and
then that didn't happen right and and
probably shouldn't have
uh
and then one day sandler just called me
and just said
we're gonna do you don't mess with the
zohan
and that was
10 years later
10 years later and
smigiel rewrote it and got it ready to
go and
it was a big
hit and hit a window where people
were willing to laugh about
conflict because it really was a satire
of the ridiculousness of people fighting
and not understanding each other not
caring about each other i mean it's a
very silly movie but that was the idea
that you could do a really goofy movie
that in his heart was about
that
it's ridiculous that this that it's just
an endless cycle of of violence we
obviously weren't getting into any real
issues right of the middle east but
somehow it happened at a time when
it had quieted down enough where people
really enjoyed the movie yeah do you
miss
any project from yesteryear like over
the years all these projects you have is
there one that you just like got to make
that some day got to make that someday